[Musique]
nous
les algues ont quitté paris de ce
paysage familier nous reste aujourd'hui
ces silhouettes dont l'aspect parle à
notre souvenir d'un temps qui n'est déjà
plus mais les grands pavillons de
baltard orgueil du second empire
en perdant leur rôle initial en ont
trouvé un autre
malgré ce vide qui les habite désormais
à cause de lui peut-être leur existence
continue ils sont devenus des témoins
avec la fin des halles commence le récit
des halles récit des halles mémoire du
plus vieux quartiers de paris de celui
qui au coeur de la ville depuis dix
siècles
jour après jour la nourrit
le marché n'est c'est avec la nuit
mélange complexe d'une tradition
moyenâgeuse et de structures du siècle
dernier les halles avec leurs gestes et
leurs langages appartenait déjà au passé
à
la véritable mémoire de ce quartier
c'était la rumeur du carreau et c'est
avec les gens des halles que nous sommes
partis à la recherche du temps perdu à
la recherche de ce dernier demi siècle à
la fois si proche et si lointain déjà
noté - restent ceux qui ont vécu cette
époque révolue notre récit et collectif
il est de mémoire d'homme
[Musique]
or
ainsi jal ont tapé pu voir des
terminales bac samedi mais alors
vraiment je ne peux pas aujourd'hui cet
handicap leurs avoirs
andré andres est née 120 km 100 kg alors
des à nyon là alors 2 oignons mars andré
la hamaide dallas 2 oignons ici là
depuis 1918
irène cardon étaient approvisionnées
deux cas une échalote elle vendait d'ici
les produits qu'elles achetaient aux
maraîchers le céleri branche le pommeau
ferry
[Applaudissements]
foucque était un maraîcher d'argent mais
il préférerait vendre lui même ses
légumes
il venait régulièrement depuis 30 ans
on a bon goût
c'est la fête ailleurs
et puis un peu détaillé son temps de
charge de famille
elle est d'aider les personnes droguées
susan était la plus ancienne vendeuse
d'irène cardon elles ont commencé
ensemble en vendant des poires ou à la
sauvette rue montorgueil
on l'appelait d'aidé de 100 métiers
aujourd'hui disparus
il était à seurre il montait d'état de
légumes en boîte ou en vrac
le bistrot de marius c'était la médaille
d'or juste en face du pavillon de la
marée
son père y était arrivé en 1893
marius est pratiquement nez dans les
halles avant la gare de 14 avait
exactement huit ans à la déclaration de
guerre 1914 ou une autre série 14 8 ans
alors j'étais petit montage est là et
bien dire bien avec la région parisienne
qui fournissait le ravitaillement de
paris on connaissait ni la province nice
qui vient des colonies en train tout ce
que l'on connaît maintenant comme tout
le monde peut le connaître
le marché était beaucoup plus pratique
beaucoup plus restreint paris avait de
la marchandise l'été comme il l aime
énormément les jeunes big été scindée du
chou on avait de la marchandise des
palaiseau on avait de la marchandise
deschambault xi on avait de sarcelles
quai d'orsay nos chers sarcelles alors
qu'ils donnent énormément de
marchandises des contres et les
alentours donne énormément de
marchandises allons les progrès se
ravitailler à la province sa démarche
est abaissée par voiture avec leur
chapeau à ce moment là il y avait quoi
de s'était pas il pour baby les
commandes et le côté noir et ils s'en
allaient généralement de montesson tout
le coup de trois heures renard 3h15 3h30
au grand maximum est fait est fait à peu
près trois heures pour venir
bon c'était pour les charniers qui les
conduisait c'était le shabbat
huit chantiers au site au pied des tul
un voyage qui ronflait tu peux pas eu
deux jours et devient c'est un passé
quand ils aèrent souvent le soir à
cheval à arriver là le patron de la
bndes avertir de cheval connaissaient
ils connaissent l itinéraire pour
arriver 114e rambuteau grave crise avec
son père et on allait là ils arrivaient
tout seul est une fois mais bloguera ses
talons c'est arrivé quelques
cultivateurs que je connaissais de
gestion du site et les nombres enfin ça
ne dira rien fait elle va descendre pas
de voiture on disait mr tiens qu'est ce
que fait le père coupable au nom soit
près de rabat il dormait encore dans la
voiture le cheval était arrêtée on le
réveille et qui il était arrivé à
domicile il ya des débats des prix qui
détourne le discours n'était pas
intéressant intelligent de leur part
mais remporte s'ouvrait donc on peut
leur faire des blagues
oui il écoutait dans la mauvaise
itinéraire et où il se retrouvait le
gars roubaix etc ou des bars je vais
vous dire enfin que j'ai je peux citer
le nom le kit de batterie il existe
toujours n'existe pas qui dit tout aux
maux du monde
la voiture assure l'onu elle je les
trouvais place de la bastille en plein
hiver magnitude de vous dire que je
descendais de montreuil par le travail
que j'ai fait arrêter le grand bain je
suis bon tissu le sujet du monde la
voiture est de retour en mayardit est
bien le seul est arrivé ici on est
arrivé dans les alpes at-on demandé s'il
y arrive le shalita en écume
cependant le marché ne se limitait pas
aux fruits et aux légumes depuis
l'origine on y à toujours trouver de
tout et comme toute arrivée presque en
même temps il en résultait pour qu'ils
ne connaissaient pas l'organisation des
choses
une grande confusion apparente
[Musique]
saoulé babillon se trouvaient les
mandataires les marchandises ne leur
appartenait pas il se contentait de les
vendre pour le compte d'expéditeurs de
province en prélevant d'une commission
au passage
et toi ça va oyonnax qui ça il y en a
qui sont parfaits arrivé en 1915 louis
delprat était au pavillon 5 le plus
ancien des mandataires de la viande
[Musique]
la santé est bonne ouïe et pendant que
les guimbardes des maraîchers arrivés
des banlieues les camions à chevaux des
transporteurs de viande faisait la
navette entre les allez les gars
doucet était l'un de ceux qui
conduisaient c'est chaud il avait
commencé à 16 ans et demi en 1920 à
l'époque la viande arriver surtout de
certaines régions
en principe tout le centre de la france
pour le nord et l'est
même la bretagne vous savez de bretagne
la vendée
quelle heure on descendait de
charente-maritime la charente
tout le monde la france et c'était les
transférer des camionneurs qui qui
prenait cette marchandise là il passait
à l'octroi naturellement puisque à
l'époque avait l'octroi et puis à mener
c'est sur le accueilli si nous on
dormait pas dans la voiture je marchais
dans maison la voiture quand les ce cas
nous fallait quand on participe à la
stratégie secours a donc sonné l'alarmé
l'appareil
il y avait une concurrence qui se
faisait à l'époque il y avait deux
maisons comprenez vous alors des fois on
était mécontents du don disait je vais
aller chez une autre
alors forcément quand on pouvait
s'emmerder lingotto respecte doit on le
faisait quoi alors moi j'avais donné
l'ordre à mes voitures à chevaux quand
il arrivait la banque s'était engagée
dans la rue de la monnaie je dois
remiser rester dans le milieu même si le
type licorne derrière vous vous restez
dans le milieu vous rentrez entre en jeu
mais ça me faisait pas un petit peu des
fois de la cia des fois que j'ai eu des
petits accrochages quoi c'est un endroit
qui m'avait fait de lâcher on se ferait
pas de cadeau quand même un cadeau aux
dépens des chacun son drapeau
si avec les arrivages commencé la course
c'est que la nuit était l'unité de temps
du marché on savait qu'au matin paris
allait exiger place nette
et puis presque toutes les marchandises
exposées étaient des denrées périssables
qu'on était obligé de vendre le plus
vite possible le temps ici valait donc
beaucoup trop cher pour qu'on puisse se
permettre de le perdre
nous descendions faubourg saint denis à
grande allure de manière improbable de
manière à pouvoir arriver dans la rue
tiquetonne très vite pour avoir une
place assez assez bien pour que nous
puissions bien vendre les les voitures
venaient du pont neuf est parfait je l'a
pas la rue de rivoli et prenez la rue
des bourdonnais la rue il ya un
joaillier la rue de la lingerie qu il se
mettait il se mettait en file pour
attendre le déchargement de rongeurs du
soir il était à l'époque
parce que la décharge est à 11 heures du
soir alors à 11h09 a été obligé d'être
là pour décharger pour avoir des places
puisque les places ne sont graphiques
sont elles sont l arrivée des voitures
alors les premiers arrivés sont mieux
placés que d'autres sites suite à
l'orage et alors à 11 heures le lille y
avait un fort il y avait le fort c'était
le placier et il y avait le renfort qui
avait le numéro un antoine un
cultivateur on lui présentait le sac et
il tirait soit boules noires blanches ou
rouges
si c'était la loire c'était la banque
derrière leo derrière les bus a dit hier
comme il est toujours dit si c'était la
rouge
c'était seulement des jardiniers si
c'était la blanche c'était sous la bâche
c'était important d'avoir des bonnes
places très important parce qu'à la
marche est né tout vendu beaucoup plus
cher selon les places selon les places
c'est tout un petit peuple et gaquere y
avait des places
vous comprenez bien été placé là bas au
maroc ça n'avait pas davantage la rue
voltaire pourquoi parce que dans la rue
vacances est toujours là mais l'yonne la
meilleure vente à la rue voltaire les
gens viennent du boulevard mais c'est
tout et servait vraiment de gros écarts
d'une place à l'arrivée avaient beaucoup
énormément
ah oui parce que vous savez quand vous
étiez placé sous la manche il y avait
des plats 3,4 centimes d'écart par butt
est là vous savez que c'était pas de la
rigolade pour eux et là bas je suis le
rang des pavillons celui qui se trouvait
derrière les
et éviterait les échoppes
eh bien c'est exactement pareil mais les
meilleures places c'était laurent
c'était les coins des voûtes alors sous
l'heure ils se seraient battus entre eux
pour leur part les jaguars mais c'est ce
que je vais vous dire il va y avoir la
course non pour être le premier e
d'antan d'après ce que mon ami la
ridelle 115 915 m'a dit qu'ils faisaient
de la concorde
juste pour une oeuvre la course pour
celui car elle est mis en place
voiture moyenne wire
avant que n'arrive maraîchers des
approvisionneurs les forts des halles
délimiter précisément la surface de sol
dans chacun pouvait disposer suivant les
quantités qu'ils avaient à vendre
ainsi chaque mètre carré de rue destinée
à servir d'état l'âge prenez son prix la
chaussée devenait le carreau on appelait
cela prendre le métrage
à l'époque on mettait tout par terre on
n'avait rien en caisse il fallait que
l'on t'a scènes hot apartheid est à
l'étude et à la scarole on faisait tout
partait dans les voitures ça dépend dans
l'est croatie c'était à la première
saison car pur au mois d'aout oui
fin juillet tu voiture de navettes sable
ça dure les voitures du navet sauve sa
de la saison dure est à peu près quinze
jours trois semaines à montesson alors
là c'était du panache et il y avait tout
la carotte navet poireau
il y avait des quelques oignons et voilà
que le carreau la première voiture c'est
le composent l as a fêté au point là
inclut le long
le hac eu au trottoir il y avait un
passeur qui était en haut des ridelles
un deuxième qui étaient au milieu deux
obus à peu près au milieu si on
partageait la distance comprenez c'est
moi qui étais long du trottoir
non du tout mais alors on portait pesé
mais de ce côté et on travaille à une
moyenne de 2800 3000 votes à l'heure
pour que ce soit je m en tape de
travailler à cette cadence là un
véritable travail de brut quoi comme
vous aviez vous étiez tous seront
invités à peu près une soixantaine comme
ça sur le camp alors il dit de vous dire
qu'elle n'était pas du tout cuit puis
des fois il y avait les crocs et les
croquants qui est du gala c'est parce
qu'on n'avait pas encore assez vite
alors on les envoyait suggère au delà et
moi quand je me suis trouvé un outil
issu de cette [ __ ] de wet on en avait
un qui me suis trouvé dans le milieu
espace est là mais qu'est ce qui est
arrivé lancé rien j'étais avec le client
donc radieux ont dû travailler on
discutait d'un surtout de me suis
retrouvé au vu de la voiture engloutie
puis on est tous les tous les douze
jours l'été c'est le moment de dire eh
bien il a fallu qu'on dépose tout ce qui
compte
corbeil le par on aurait dit qu'il y
avait une main magique qui avait tout
pousse et ça a duré jusqu à quand le
passage
écoutez voir jusqu'en 48,50 bas après ça
le travail complètement changé
comment c'est à dire que
le boat page a été supprimée et
jean-louis la marchandise au lieu de la
mort d'ilan concurrence accc
mais alors qui croire aux oreilles des
vagues de bretons des tas de sacs puis
des caisses voilà vous avez été tués par
les casser les sacs voilà exactement
je
[Musique]
4 1 qui était chargé on se souvient du
nord de les coucher une heure par pierre
sont des paillettes dans les capsules et
bayal chemra j'avais beaucoup de femmes
qui dormaient lavagna venez pas me
décembre il y avait des cultivateurs
d'un côté puis à une équipe a des doutes
c'est vrai mais c'est la vérité
oui ça c'est exact c'est bien dormir là
aussi avery avait envie pareil s'étaient
mélangés
il y avait les deux cas c'est bien un
franc complet oui la vie s'était mélangé
il ya trop de salariés prenaient des
masses m
ici on avait eu la veille avec 225
matelas puis l'autre canal et autant 25
ans couché de 51 au jeu tout à fait
gratuitement un titre à titre gratuit
ont été les vrais 18 20 onkyo une
paillasse chacun sa paillasse et puis à
2 heures du matin une heure et demie
pour gainey et nous réveiller
à l'époque tout le monde à bord à la
vente moi j'ai vu garder mon corps et du
mardi jusqu'au dimanche après midi c'est
bien une fois par semaine et votre
patronaux c'est pour l'abattre en de
pareilles
or après on allait retravailler on teste
un belle endormie une heure et remettez
ça endormi e 4 5 heures par jour en deux
trois fois monsieur decottignies dite
coco était fort des halles il a passé
entre autres sept ans où les pavillons
de la viande
au mieux de sa forme il pesait plus de
140 kg il appelait cela sans quoi de
croisière
[Musique]
le coltiner l'avion nous l'apprenions
dans les camions qui venait de
l'abattoir et on les a menés ici on est
accroché c'est quelle distance à
parcourir pour deux fois 40 dans
quarantaine de mètres au maximum et en
tête de train ont besoin ça pèse combien
être comme ça écoutez je sais c'est
marqué d'ailleurs ses marques et fois
bonjour
enfin ça faisait deux fois sont 130 140
kg les moyens j'en avais des 225 kg il y
en avait des 100 kg ça c'était un petit
peu ce suivant la qualité de la viande
est alors chaque bayol compris combien
de tonnes 5 par shadow
[Musique]
en principe de tonnes 5 par cheval alors
une fait j'avais arrive une petite
pochette y avait des petites flèches qui
faisait trois tables c'était xs les
grosses l'écho chaumières on leur
mettait entre 4000 et st quatre mille
cinq cents à 5 tonnes bon et alors pour
défaire une voiture comme ça mais bien à
l'effort qui prenaient une voiture comme
ça comme la mettons cette voiture qui
est devant celle poste au douar si elle
ne bougeait pas de place de deux formes
mettait entre 25 à 30 minutes pour faire
5 tonnes pour faire 5-2 ouais et il en
faisait combien dans la nuit comme ces
rabat ils arrêtaient pas avec une selon
les arrivages
[Musique]
prenez les collabos
trop chaud
[Musique]
une équipe de fort chargé parfois
jusqu'à 1000 2002 dans l'année mais
certaines années la surabondance était
générale et de telles quantités de
nourriture étaient entreposés aux halles
que le marché ne pouvaient plus les
contenir
est ce que vous vous rappelez deux jours
ou d'époque où il ya eu encore plus de
marchandises que ça y est l'été le
printemps 28 29 29
alors là on ne savait plus où la m ouais
j'en ai vu
photo el habchi d'un plat du chapelet à
sarah bernhardt je vous dis la voiture à
francis alain elle a manqué de tomber
dans le métro rue de rivoli
c'est d'arrêter assad voilà la nage
pourquoi peut-être d'une mauvaise
manoeuvre absolument rien pour moi qui
conduisais ne savait plus où mettre les
marchandises quoi on savait toujours où
la bête mais un accord qui pensaient où
il avait été envoyé au bail écouter voir
tu leur en demander
au deuxième rang issus de rang des déçus
troisièmement la l'état il était au cern
il avait en début dé pas monté sur le
tard quand j'étais d'état de nyon
processus temps pour vous dire mon teint
beaucoup plus au froid et sous la pluie
pourrait plus y arriver
[Musique]
oh
il y avait des remarques avant il y
avait à l'époque il y avait des forts
moi je me souviens certains types
c'était c'était des hercules c'était
dévore une fois j'avais ici un un espèce
de s'était plaint à fort c'était un
arménien a ou howard polonais ou pomme
sait d'où il sortait vous savez on
envoyait tellement il arrivait sur ici
ça restait quelques mois et puis
quelques semaines il repartait le ben
hamida prix il a pris devant is here
avant de 70 kg il l'a pris comme ça dans
ses bras et il a pris ilna il a pris le
plancher durant dans les dents et puis
il est parti avec le roux peser levant
au plateau savez ça faisait du ballon
ils avaient une dentition north cape ce
type comme j'en ai connu un homme et
bibi à la viande par exemple
c'est un monsieur qui est mort
maintenant qu'ils étaient forts vassieux
manger une calotte de trip 2 3 kg il a
mangé dans la calotte j'avais mangé 108
décortiquer les huit les mettre dans un
saladier mettre son nez challes son
vinaigre et manger ça la cuillère de
quoi il y aurait de quoi écoeurer un
cauchemar et puis après ils se tapaient
le sa calotte de dribbles de droite et
l'autre lui faisait pas peur on papa
papa mais vous auriez dit après marie
dans un garage il ou à manger leur a dit
m des mois de gillot à monsieur qu'ils
aient d'abord le poids public qui se
posait pas parce que le public fait 140
kilos quand il mentait je suis bloqué là
et bloqué la bascule à elle avait été
connue bilili à la viande
c'était un énormément connu il avait
inventé de la pierre quand il pousse à y
sont rares la vallée sur 100 kg et adam
janosik catch up pourrait citer la
véritable pierre parent qui sait comment
on devenait force et coco en faisant
un concours fallait déposer la demande à
monsieur
le préfet de police qui vous convoquez
est important et visite médicale un
examen de votre famille et puis un jour
on vous convoquera s'est passé l'examen
de corps des halles c'est à dire
apporter 200 kilos pendant 50 m dos m ça
se passait à la hot-line et puis alors
en même temps les 200 kg se servait tout
de même à faire une élimination diminue
c'est à dire que par exemple il se
présentait 600 concurrents prenaient les
plus forts pour être sûr d'avoir les
mythes de la corporation
j'ai pu lâcher quand même un petit peu
leur l'arithmétique est il français pour
parler à leurs problèmes
puis ça s'est très bien passé ce qu'on
vous demande est et surtout de porter
des 100 kg c'est un oui mais enfin vous
aviez une note éliminatoire à la dictée
si vous faisiez plus de suffoquer cinq
photos ne sont pas saturés éliminé parce
qu'il y avait un grand nombre
un grand nombre de candidats alors je
choisis ce matin commente à dire d'où
venaient les candidats
les candidats et on est un peu d'un peu
de partout évidemment on enfin les gros
contingent était surtout fourni par des
pays pauvres savoie auvergne
même limousin voyez-vous des pays les
gens en principe ces expatriés
parce que où il ya les ans les gens ce
patrimoine savoyard est épaulé en france
on y venait en france dure à paris et ce
dernier également
sert bien les gones servi à l'écossé ben
oui ça va bon
serre les coudes
ça va
serrent les coudes attention à la brosse
là
attention un serre les coudes ça va
ça va
doucement doucement doucement doucement
doucement
alors voilà
[Musique]
un peu après l'ouverture du carreau et
l'arrivée de la viande les deux
pavillons de la marée en fait en
activité
au poisson on avait la réputation de par
les eaux peut-être d'ailleurs y mettant
une certaine coquetterie
peut-être fallait-il donner de soi même
une image fidèle à la tradition
après tout les dames de la halle les
poissarde étaient de très anciennes
figures de la mythologie parisienne
depuis 1923
jeannette égard 2 l'existence de son
métier était rendue nécessaire par
l'interdiction absolue fait aux
acheteurs d'emporter immédiatement la
marchandise par des pavillons les
caisses devait d'abord être déposées
auprès des gardes
[Musique]
on appelle un
bague ornée là
la journée
et
je ne veux pas partir
cwi
alors catherine était la doyenne des
gars 2 son travail consistait donc à
surveiller une certaine surface de
trottoirs sur laquelle on entreposait
temporairement le poisson les acheteurs
venaient ensuite les chercher chacun à
son tour
ou plutôt tous en même temps
marie louise était poissonnier à vos
détails sur un marché d'aubervilliers
elle venait tous les jours acheter aux
halles
car voir g
c'est parfait
en couple
un gros oui mais alors combien gagner la
prochaine
c'était à quel moment vous êtes arrivé
en 1918
et quand mon mari est revenu de la
guerre donc qu'il y avait eu enfin il me
dit moi je me pose que tu as été
employée ça ça n'a rien à faire
et puis surtout vous sur les marchés
alors moi j'ai du coup on a des enfants
ça sera pour eux ça sera pour les dents
niveau de 40 en train de basculer moment
là on avait sa petite vie tranquille
tout le même
alors je les ai traduit superflu pour
les enfants et j'ai passé des et ma foi
je suis resté comme ça
madame m'en sers vendait de la salle
izzo la moyenne
vous êtes arrivé quand je suis arrivé à
15 ans et vous avez quel âge 83
bientôt c'est à dire vous êtes en 1900 à
peu près après oui oui à peu près oui
pour moi qui étais ménagères avant alors
comprenez vous et ça m'a surpris qu
après 1 c'était c'était parfait me suis
mis l'ambiance est au dessus mais ça
vous a su faute et pourquoi parce que je
n'étais pas du tout parce que ça en
jette en intérieur de la l'effort tous
de tous sont nominatifs pour deux mois
ça lui faisait pas peur de venir au 1,6
à m'ennuyais un peu parce que c'était
pas mon genre vous savez on dit beaucoup
de choses là dessus evènement on était
pas et c'était peut-être vivre comme
langage mais c'était on est étonné olala
messieurs comprend jamais entendu
c'était des femmes de théâtre la jolie
très joli ce n'était pas mon jour du jeu
youtube ça c'est le langage est
entièrement libre et il est amical en
même temps samuel tu serais un bilan ne
consacre pas il y tient bon avec un
conte qu'à bamako est un con c'est vrai
ça fait partie du boulot tu es l'allant
et puis on appelait le monde en a
pleinement deux étudiants qui
n'achetaient pas on disait des choses
désagréables que moi j'ai jamais dis
comme ça j'ai toujours été ma part été
payant plus lourds dommages du manga
qu'est ce que tu peux être con quand
même d'avoir travaillé écouté on n'est
pas au faubourg saint-honoré dans les
airs dans les ateliers c'est peut-être
chez leur maman disait toujours je t'en
prie ne dit jamais été aussi ceux qui
travaillent aux poissons à ne dis pas ça
[Musique]
après six habitées s'est habitué à des
idées mon trou après elle est battue de
la ville d'aujourd'hui
enfin vous savez j'ai eu mes péripéties
bien quand on est une femme seule dans
le commerçant c'est pas rien
il
à partir de 4 heures du matin la
marchandise bien en place arrivé le
moment le plus important de la nuit le
face à face des vendeurs et des
acheteurs car toute cette nourriture à
l'état l'âge il allait falloir la vendre
tout est donc prêt pour recevoir les
clients semi grossistes et détaillants
pouvait arriver
il était attendu maurice le goas lui
était acheteur depuis 40 ans toutes les
nuits il faisait son tour de marché
il prenait la température du caroux chez
moi je donne un coup d'oeil dans les
rues en passant je vois les appeaux et
je me dis bon ba aujourd'hui gemalto m'a
touché besoin de de ce style se la
jouait les quantités sur le marché et je
dis bon bah ce matin je leur apprends
cause des péchés la gestion premier ça
j'aurais le temps et vient d'où elle
tient le premier commence à lundi voilà
ça fait tenté une maison 3 on pas alors
je m'en vais plus loin même dit la
boissée de 50 alors marchander et
gagnent je donne au moins cher et alors
je discute
las les hommes qui peut voir ce qu'il y
avait énormément de marchandises sur le
cordon et on s'écoutait habituellement
les cours que l'on vendait l'un ou
l'autre
alors lorsqu'il y avait une marchandise
qui partait beaucoup plus que l'autre
eh bien on disait il faut il faut pas
vous faut augmenter le cours sur la
marchandise et quelques propre idée sur
une autre marchandise
le cours se fait automatiquement ça
n'est pas la quantité de marchandises
que vous avez son diable on n'y trouve
rien beaucoup de marchands de giroud
pour le doucement et puis c'est envahir
ou noire fendue antonio ripaille là pour
faire tout ça se décide comme ça c'est
le site ou bien tout cela tout seul puis
c'est toujours pareil quand il n'a qu'a
vendu en direct a vendu jeudi temps il
marche avant les émeutes il est une
heure du matin ou deux heures lors du
pot offert des frondes peut aider fois
sa riche et ne faudrait-il pas c'est la
bourse
la doute savamment baisse on monte ça
dépend comment les goûts parce que c'est
quand il ya beaucoup de marchandises qui
ne se vend pas il faut la mort et
quelques fois vous avez le marchand dit
ce qui se vend alors il faut faire
attention attention vous pas
quant aux clients arrivent moi j'ai vu
qui en fait arrivé un jour elle m'avait
acheté de la chicorée ça je me rappelle
j'étais rue baltes 1 il m'avait presque
acheter tout monte à elle m'a dit j'ai
dit comme on reste chez kelme achètent
beaucoup comme ça il ya quelque chose
qui tourne pas bien
faut que je me renseigne alors me suis
rendu compte que je m'étais fait avoir
encore fait une affaire dont on n'a pas
fait une affaire on achète toujours trop
tôt ou trop tard
est-ce qu'il y en a dans tes travel
or ben oui des marchandises par exemple
j'ai vu acheté des pouvoirs être pressé
le matin dans les avoir parce que
j'avais besoin de leur bonheur il
s'entend que ça allait s'effondrer
je le savais que ça allait finir un prix
relativement bas mais comme il fallait
tu peux le voir ça mais j'en avais
besoin plus que c'est cela que je
voulais bon bah et maintenant a pris et
puis je les payais quoi but je savais
pertinemment que j'aurais pu la voir et
je dors a eu dix fois moins 2 heures
toutes ont un coût genre empêché de la
tomate
mon collègue est l'arbre est grand il
atteint 22 25 franc avec moi j'avais les
150 francs en l'espace de cinq heures de
temps à janot n'était pas content jour
la tête aux matelas 1 à te rappelles tu
es tout jeune à ce moment là un autre
fois on a rangé les jeunes enfin on
avait tendance à par exemple des choses
camoufler marchandises camoufler matin
avec le pauliste mans avec les produits
qui doivent arriver avec un certain
calibre et autres les choses se
régularise beaucoup plus qu'autrefois
main droite loi ont noté par exemple le
dessus la belle marchandise puis en
seconde
des fois ça l'est toujours se méfier
toujours être là des fossiles et steve
et des petits secrets aussi dans la
manière de faire un tabac
mon propre production il y avait quand
même la marchandise qui était plus belle
que d'autres dont la wii hoballah là la
question de la parure bon ben vous avez
quand c'était la marchandise uniforme
n'y avait pas de ta rue à faire il ya
des vraies et par contre il y avait de
la marchandise à gratte alors qu'il
fallait là justement quand la
marchandise y arriver le révèle habitée
de côté puis alors le dessus
puis le dessus pour betty de 3 métiers
la marchandise pour gaza il a rangé et
ça c'est ce qu'on appelait paris la
marche anglars i like i'm not i 6 août
par odon saison c'était interdit mais le
côté dans le bal des mains celles
choisies on était très contents
lorsqu'on arrivait tout était bien rangé
parce que on attendait tant bien rangé
sa attirer le client et on vendait
automatiquement
ce n'est pas la même pour choisir la
marchandise volée un coup d'oeil non ah
bah vous savez le coup d'oeil d'une
marche dans des cas présentés pendant
toute ma jeunesse même bien après on se
fait ici des veaux dévouement ont fait
des veaux souffre et leveaux paraissait
comprenait le cuissot tout ça paraissait
beaucoup savaient plus à spec au point
de vue comme ça à lèvres
coup d'oeil il n'avait plus de
conformation puisse dépouillé mieux mais
il avait beaucoup moins de conservation
il y avait de l'air dans tous les
muscles
alors maintenant je crois bien que le
service sanitaire a interdit
complètement soufflé le meilleur quand
tout est arrivé en caisse c'est un
progrès ça y est plus besoin de les
peser vous saviez le poids à cet effet
ah oui oh ben ça l'épreuve le savait on
peut en causer sa des poids parce qu'on
vous annonce facilement 25 kg il y en a
il y en a 22 ans
la quête ça se faisait fréquemment ça ça
se faisait presque oui j'avais pas
toujours non là le conte sa perle
poisson en route
alors vous protestez mon avis mais à
l'acier ont protesté et bien le nom là
on vous vendez pas j'ai vu une fois
ménagé à la bastille
belle petite raie elle me dit madame
royal trois matches on en pourra bloquer
mon turbo gens vous amende ou simplement
une bonne puis ben j'ai dit allez-y
c'est une petite reine
elle a pas coupé et elle a payé le prix
d'un turbo en profite
quand ils voyent qui peut même même que
vous connaissance ils peuvent vous
arranger le silo bénéfice de sa reine
nour arrivé de vous vendre un article de
100 points il vous demande 300 si vous
vous laissez faire un vous savez de la
défense henri faisait faire poser pour
dissiper défense l'injecteur comme ça la
merde alors
[Applaudissements]
je phobie sans ballon sur la tête là je
fais l'orissa et pattes d'eph regarde
oui sur celui-là d'accord mais sur
l'autre regarde
bon bah tu tombes sur un colis
malheureux mais c'est pas une affaire
donc ce gamin je te fais lui semblait
trop bien pour moi que je vais te tais
comptait 9 50
rabat avec des dix dont elle donne ni
des quartiers à 808 oui des quartiers
chics ou beckett kovac tu veux mettre un
8 5 ans oui oui pourquoi je me fais voir
s'il a basculé pour pas dire autrement
alors vas-y
qu'est-ce que tu te gêne dans cette
sanction après déjà nous faudra user ou
non la part de marché des films à 32,50
points
c'est pour elles on compte 4 à 18 ans
donc il a compté les voix que j'ai
remboursé déjà fait tomber tu déconnes à
l'énoncé parole jean philippe brandt
l'état
je reste est vendu en mairie quand même
et ça
basket ball voilà bah ouais mais c'est
pas normal
alors non je te fais d'autres gaza comme
je t'ai dis pas que c'est un plaisir je
bouge 150 da le kilo en export que je
serai bien les maîtres aux galeries de
par howard c'est ma moyenne la moyens à
ces comme on dit en termes de métier
c'est du pifomètre quoi il faut il faut
avoir une certaine habitude pour pouvoir
toujours sur le dur et paulo était
vendeur aux poissons il suffirait il
suffisait d'avoir envoyé un peu où j'ai
un peu comme ça poursuit dans 10 des
adresses un petit bourg d'oisans j
essaye de la tempête
nathan p ça commençait à permettre de
vendre le poisson déjà un peu plus cher
c'est à dire attention il est demain il
y aura rien alors je sais sa remontée de
masse ou à ce moment la vie sauve un
choix qui nous regardent la température
qui fait un contrat énorme aimant vous
savez de partants fluviaux ou sitôt que
la rampe
comment la rampe d'escalier qu'on a un
peu c'est un mauvais temps pour la
viande à elle devient moins at elle
devient la moins de conservation le
boucher charge moins que par toutes
parts en 5e ton propre pas là la viande
oui alors il ya des inspecteurs vague ya
les arrivées jeudi à la période de
l'année
kamerhe pop en effet quand les gens
touchent leur paye c'est ça qui est
intéressant
les fans noir c'est toujours beau milieu
de la mode et du moins c'est ça commence
à tirer mais quand arrive le 20 mai et
plutôt à l'aise mais même vous
cultivateurs qui vendit ol vous le
santal ensemble on s'entend que les gens
et touchent leurs plus tôt 25 celle là
c'est bon si je crois peut produire
qu'après la baisse c'est vrai les
ouvriers y travaillent
gageons qu'il a de l'argent ni monde que
je suis mon apport il fait comme les
autres
mais autrement tandis que le
fonctionnaire c'est pas la mouche on est
le fonctionnaire il attend manger dans
deux étangs plus est ce que vous sentiez
justement tante en avait moins de paye
il y avait le gaz du zimbawe y avait
tout ça alors c'était vers le 20 à paye
et puis le 5
alors là on savait qu'on allait faire
des bonnes semaines on saute par exemple
que la période d'été homologué de retour
de vacances les gens les gens vont
au moins d'argent et pas procès qu'on a
ce moment la tâche trop mou alors ça ça
ce sont tous ces événements spéciaux
c'est sûr c'est un peu comme le bâtiment
ouais c'est un peu comme partie du
bâtiment va tout va mais en général s'il
ya une valve rose c'est parce que en
général cela pour ne plus lier ce qui se
passait quand les cours s'effondrent
elles se négocient en vain c'était
mauvais pour examiner dans la salle et
rentrer en collaboration il fallait sont
alors sauvagement c'était un grand
moment de dire il faut y aller alors là
c'est quoi s'étaient enchaînés pour
celui qui aurait vendu 8
la et vendez c'est pas un profil vous
tapez un sentier c'est oui donc emmené
pour pour l'écurie la marchandise qu'on
avait mais je dirai ce que est ce que en
dessous d'un certain chiffre parce
qu'ils n'arrivent de façon de le bande
parle moi si ça réussit qu'est ce qui se
passe souvent on serait arrivé que
s'était vendu à des prix insignifiants
d'une peur et que malheureusement ce qui
leur ait pas été vendu ça leur d'euros
le trou c'était la saison où partaient
la marchandise avariée
car lorsque les cours étaient trop bas
il arrivait que le poisson se gâte
à force d'attendre quand le vent
d'après les chiffres officiels de la
préfecture de la seine on a jeté en 1968
943 tonnes de poissons
vers 5 heures du matin les routiers
mettez les halles en état de siège
les premiers camions automobile était
apparu en 1925 et vers 1930 les
transports routiers avaient commencé à
livrer la viande de la province vers
paris
douce et le meneur de viande à cette
époque conduisait encore ses voitures à
chevaux il a donc connu le temps de la
concurrence
[Musique]
nous avons retrouvé à des camionneurs
qui faisait les halles à ce moment là
monsieur pâris pour faire
la route on était un des premiers outils
a apporté la viande sur paris vous
veniez 12 rames net chansard à parité
les deux centres des tracts
c'est un peu la nsa de prendre trente
quatre 34 35
on a commencé exactement dans ces
années-là quoi mais ça fait tout de
distance sur 7 525 km vous mettez
combien de temps qu'on fait instaurer
nos métiers à 12 heures 12h03 faire pour
tout voir
et encore masquée par circulation
pourquoi fallait pas faire moins et pour
l'horaire des halles pour la vente parce
que les expéditeurs il nous fallait
partir toujours à la dernière minute par
rapport aux autres
qu'est ce que nous faisions la
concurrence aux semaines faire alors on
ne pouvait pas partir avant le train on
avait toujours plus de chance de partir
après 40 parce que les créateurs nous
tenait toujours à la dernière minute
la marche en ville pour la marchandise
mais si par exemple le fait d'arriver
plus tôt quoi savander mieux c'est à
dire que ça jouait pas un rôle sur les
premières heures oui mais vers 6 5h30 6h
7h du matin ça joue un rôle
vous prenez pas ce que la vente était
commencé là c'était sauve-qui-peut là à
la sortie peur parce que je vous assure
qu'il fallait prendre beaucoup de
voitures sur la route
en plus de ça les routes n'était pas
aussi bonne qu'aujourd'hui et camion
n'avait pas de point
alors il fallait pas penser à avoir
beaucoup de voix se répondent nouvelle
marque un cinquième était plus rapide
que les voitures
il faut lancer on peut nous arrêter
maintenant c'est fini ça il fallait pour
s'arrêter il fallait bien
bon kilomètre les mois de la terre vous
attraper ce moment les été très exigeant
on arrivait à un quart d'heure de retard
10 ans celui-là il a livré plutôt peu
admettons les vents de la creuse sont
arrivés un quart d'heure plus tôt dans
tel poste que dans le mien est alors
qu'elle s'amusait sa vie des fois c'est
bien souvent c'est énorme pour la vente
oui parce que c'est une question l'avant
vous savez c'est une question d'heures
pour ça on descendait tout et laisse
entendre ou lettres pour les plus vite à
descendre du chêne vert de trois
kilomètres en descente et ça ouais a330
peut-être avec les camions notre mariage
il fallait pas s'amuser retard ou
qu'elle cherchait produit des noises il
est bien souvent si je voulais les
emmerder les emmerder pas ce qu'est la
voiture je la mette en travers ou
n'importe quoi il pourrait passer ici
s'il pouvait passer mais des faits il
avait pas de faits ce qu'on se remette
entre deux à comprenez tandis que si je
serai bien mais voiture moi j'ai laissé
une place pour tenir
vous disiez lui perdu si vous avez connu
la cenap le roi lui c'est elle c'est lui
qui faisait un petit peu ce qu'ils
voulaient cet essentiel
c'était lui qui dirigeait un peu les
ailes le pavillon à viande
il était chez lui ce qu'ils voulaient
s'il voulait que vous déchargez tard des
profs assez lent
parce qu'avec ses chocolats qui savait
parler la route
le mandataire vous être apaisé alors que
tu auras un compte à l'imbécile lui
arrive avant toi et c est journellement
et ainsi de suite alors en sauget des
vacheries comme ça du tout alors si
quelquefois pour en arriver ici que lui
mettez ces secours leurs travers en long
et en large pourquoi que l'on rentre
alors automatiquement c'était encore une
demi heure de perdue mais il était fort
pour ça il savait les faire marcher les
mains quand il fallait même gandhi
valait pas bon à nous était pas
tellement facile
ils avaient ils avaient la part plus
facile que nous parce que les jo c'était
des vieilles charrettes alors il arraché
les ailes il arrachait tout ça hein
c'était pas facile qu'on leur arrache un
panneau dans puisque c'est à dire que
même si je serais pour les cornières les
unes contre les autres je pouvais
prendre beaucoup plus de place et où
vous pouvez plus placé si l'armée près
c'était une perte de temps
enfin du jeune américain cette huile
c'était c'était cette technique
empêchait tout âge et il lui tout seul
la maaf à lui tout seul il savait faire
commander les autres mais enfin il était
le grand patron des élus oui il dit moi
si j'avais eu mes roues à telle heure
j'ai répondu c'est là at elle pris
tandis que là j'ai plus de clients qui
vont prendre cette marchandise à ou
alors je pensais de baisser des prix
alors si ça continue ben moi je vous
prêt à payer la différence alors
automatiquement on était obligé de payer
le pays à la laurent payer c'était une
amende pour l'été un genre d'amande
aimant et de maintenance était pas une
amende si vous voulez
c'était pertes à la vente et le pressage
et avait perdu tendu kg la vente parce
qu'on est arrivé en retard
de combien de temps ont quelquefois
juste deux heures de temps peut
s'inquiéter pour toute là ce moment là
les expéditeurs et on avait souvent qui
était à paris may
presque plus n'étant pas dans le temps
et dans le temps il n'a surveiller leur
arrivages mais ne se faisaient pas voir
c'est probable
il se cachait est ce qu'un seul arrêt
17e rgp pas ma came note d'arrivée ainsi
de suite il sa wii en principe on
n'était pas un mois sans voir un
expéditeur
il ya dire qu'on est tous les jours mais
pourquoi il est à parier que dans leur
métier les années fric y voit l'avion
brisé non puis je reste en contact avec
les mandataires parce qu'il y en avait
qui étaient plus ou moins compte en or
de leurs mandataires un orri cherché
autre part une ainsi de suite bien
souvent fatalement fallait il prendre
sûrement savez sur le sommeil parce
qu'ils ont des idées tient elle à intel
qui lui rend breuvage une avenue aux
folies bergères ou ailleurs c'était le
coup classique ce salarié reste est en
principe le matin jusqu'à 11 heures ici
après on allait déjeuner ensemble
et puis après on sortait on a les
secours ce bout de trop autre part au
fond c'était à qui s'occuperait lemieux
de l'expéditeur a paru normal ça joue un
rôle pour lui les spectateurs vous me
direz c'est sa bande qui l'intéressent
et c'était sa bande qui l'intéressait
même s'il avait des copains avec moi si
j'ai amené sa marchandise à l'heure du
casse toi bien vendu est resté copains
mais si jamais en retard et j'ai pas de
copain c'est malgré la tournée des
grands ducs c'était normal hein c'est
humain et ubuntu sein du renamo n'a pas
tout le monde entend quand même mais
quatre sont bien cinq six ans chance
inouïe 5 6 ans jusqu'à ce que les
joueurs ont les se sont éliminés après
les routiers se sont amplifiées oui
après les grèves de 36 monaco comme je
vous l'avais
on a commencé à vendre oui ça c'est bien
éliminer parce qu'on est resté cinq ans
trois jours gras et 20 36 alors fallait
les sortir feu les lys c'est plus comme
des voitures on est risqué en grève
après avec des camions on avec la clé à
mettre sous la porte c'est tout tandis
que des secours s'est comparé à les
nourrir les pensées et on n'avait pas
suffisamment de monde pour les sortir
comme ça ben les mandataires il pensait
plus qu'à nos la route
alors là la route on apporter quand même
la marchandise qu'elle la voyez vous si
elle arrive bien auquel arrive mal
personne nous demandaient une indemnité
qui sera arrivé avant de les choux j'ai
barré c'est de la cavalerie du fait
qu'on était concurrencé par le trafic
ce que des canaux auto de leur côté l'a
vue seule patrouille l'a commencée on en
a vendu sans donner une seule et c'est
ça qui a aidé énormément parce que là
quand même les routiers ce sont là les
mandataires ce temps aperçu qu'il y
avait une porte de sortie par rapport à
la grève parce que la grève des chemins
de fer qui s'arrêtent un seul coup y'a
plus de porte de sortie tandis que la
belle et camions ont amené la viande
mais on avait commencé avant nous alors
c'est pour ça que malgré tôt unis en
36,6 vous les routiers n'y avait pas eu
ce gros on nous ne l'a jamais fait
preuve d'un mètre grève
on n'est pas loin pas loin de faire la
grève pourquoi faire la grève
qu'est ce que vous voulez on était à
notre corps et ben c'est pas possible
notez vos propre patron
je
m
[Musique]
comme la soupçonne la vitre
bon
[Musique]
comment ça s'est passé pendant la guerre
il y avait de la marchandise c'est pas
pareil non face à poitiers rigolo on
avait des répartitions tous les huit
jours des fois trois jours ça dépend des
moments de sa tombe et des arrivages et
puis on avait on avait prendre parce
qu'on voulait on n'a jamais manqué de
marchandises eu énormément parce qu'on
en avait grandement avait quand même de
la famille qu avec tous les producteurs
on l'avait qui nous fournissait on avait
de la marchandise était pâle et surtout
à les charger dans les cultures et alors
on avait de la marchandise
celui qui avait de l'argent dans la
poche il a pu c'est à jour de tout le
monde qu'il ya eu des grands restaurants
au marché noir vous mangez faut dire la
vérité
donc il se fournissait par exemple à la
place saint-michel là bas
on savait le marché noir
je descendais pendant la guerre aussi
annoncé les gens aiment avec des vélos
ensuite utilisé débrouilla les gens
n'importe quoi comme être qu'on avait
tout ça c'était parti taiwan bouger même
s'ils arrivent à tanger un peu de trope
quoi est arrivé un poisson contraindre
les fai qui accuse appeler une paire de
souliers ou d'un portrait il emmenait
quelque chose c'était la vis mais
j'étais à débrouiller ce moment là on
voit ce qu'ils mangeront de marchandises
dont la marchandise il se débrouillait
pour ramener ça quand il voulait soit
qu'ils ont ordonné si c'était des tirs
apporter à ses parents dans une poule où
j'en étais sûr pourquoi reprendre à
lapins il est cependant fine on était
content d'avoir de l'audace
ils ont tous maigrir il y en a marre des
dégâts que j'ai connus très fort et
forcément ils pouvaient plus arriver à
manger ce qui m'aurait pas ce que
c'était presque journalier cédé 4 août
comme ça c'était pour moi c'était pour
une fois au hasard comme celui que j'ai
aussi très bons élèves skypower c'était
journellement alors déjà il ne pouvait
pas se réapprovisionner
ou alors ça aurait été du fait des
heureuses plus les moyens de et puis
alors après il ya eu les ont mis deux du
parti
pas de poisson pas de poisson alors
c'était tourner la manivelle la toux la
tête là que les arrêter tout et on
mangerait ça on mangeait pas bien jours
au comptoir d'abbadia l'on connaît peu
et d'anciens amis marius plus la
regarder
précision donnée inconnue la biennale
orange alors la physionomie des reconnu
alors à valider une grille 45 villes où
elle est morte peu après moi j'ai eu des
clients qui ont été déportés
j'ai eu d un couple de juifs à qui je
portais régulièrement du poisson
j'ai pu retrouver un beau matin dans
quelles circonstances où leur forte
pression adverse
je leur côté du poisson en cachette
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de voix
d'entrer dans les magasins alors qu'il y
avait encore ce qui avait 12 ans je me
rendais compte que de gaulle c'est bien
ce n'était pas drôle alors je
m'arrangerais finalement on avait quand
même des accointances ou et bien sûr
porte un petit peu de poisson parce que
je pouvais avoir aussi bien s'ils
avaient de la charcuterie sportel
quelque sorte pris 11 ans j'ai ensuite
deux gosses il y avait fin et ces gens
là ne peut pas trop dans un magasin de
l'étoile jaune
il aurait été déportés alors j'avais un
cachet porté à manger à ces gens là bien
beaux jours des débuts ont été déportés
vous avez vous prises rapporter toute
façon j'aurais termes assez avec que je
peux bien qu'on se rende pas contre ce
que le juste des gens comme les autres
engins
non
fr
avec le jour venait pour les gens des
halles le temps du repos jusqu'à la nuit
suivante
[Applaudissements]
une seule trace restait de toute cette
activité nocturne des centaines de
tonnes de résidus dont il fallait
débarrasser le carreau
à la fin était les éboueurs
[Applaudissements]
bien
pour tous ceux qui travaillaient
les halles n'était pas seulement le
marché c'était aussi une manière de
vivre cette vie à contretemps la vie
ancienne
ce sera le deuxième volet de ses
mémoires d'un vieux quartier
[Musique]